like millions of women Nicola bully had
been coping with the adverse effects of
the perimenopause details shared by her
family remind us all of the physical and
mental strain it can have but also of
the lack of awareness
for many people it comes as a surprise
and a shock because it can be very
varied but also we have a situation
where for some of our particularly some
of our GPS our practice nurses
Unfortunately they have never had formal
education about menopause the menopause
happens when women's periods stop
usually between the ages of 45 to 55 but
can start earlier there are over 30
symptoms including insomnia and night
sweats but these hormone changes can
impact mental health too for one in Four
Women the symptoms are debilitating and
for women with perimenopause they can
happen up to a year before the menstrual
cycle stops
Nicola Billy's family say that she had
been struggling with the perimenopause
and had started taking HRT to try and
cope but that in itself started causing
some severe side effects it's a reminder
that whilst this is a widely available
treatment that can be effective at
relieving symptoms for some for others
it can have a very different impact
the women's and equalities committee has
long argued that not enough is being
done to protect menopausal women we know
that the menopause will affect different
people in different ways for some it
will be much more severe than others and
I think the real challenge around the
menopause is that people are given
adequate medical support and assistance
from professionals and not stigmatized
solving those challenges means tackling
that stigma famous faces have been
campaigning for the cause for years
until their voices are heard for half
the population it may continue to feel
like a silent struggle Ashley Sky News